- Is that the kind of stuff
that you feel like you know,
you are having with your son,
the conversations,
because there's a lot
of conversations being
heard right now about everything going on
and even talking to some of my friends,
you know, they're like,
I'm having to have really hard
conversations with my kid.
They're getting their driver's license.
I'm like,Hey,
if a cop pulls you over,
I don't care what happens.
I just want you to come home.
- Right
- Like
do whatever you do Like,
are you having those
conversations as well?
- No, 'cause (mumbling) only being seven.
So it's like,
when I have to explain
what, why we're in protest,
but now with the death
(mumbling) allow me to say
it puts me in those awkward situations
that their kids are
probably a little older.
- Yeah.
(mumbling)
My little girl is six
and it's like, you know
she catches something like
the news or something.
And it's like, you know
I just have to explain it
in simple (mumbling) like
well, this is right and wrong
and this person was wrong
- right
and that's why they're crying.
But I just,
it's a very different thing,
you know?
And, and I think that's
apparent now more than ever
me having a conversation
with my little white girl
and you having a conversation
with your little boy
that's a very different conversation,
you know, So,
and I think everyone needs to
have that uncomfortable conversation that,
that exists and it's wrong.
And you know,
- yes
- This is true.
And I think when,
when you get to,
it's also very delicate.
- Yeah.
- And I always look at him and say like,
I don't want to over
exert these things to him.
And, and
just prescribe to more than design
so I (drowned by the
other speaker's voice)
it, it is different and they know how to,
like even my boy and my girl,
they're so different,
like how they receive information and,
it goes in and out his
ear and she is a sponge.
So...
I agree
yeah, know, they are all different.